everybody and welcome back to park
attacks in the last episode I finished
maple Meadows and we unlocked the
Chanute Air Field scenario and I also
have to say this is one of the scenarios
which I didn't make myself but I've been
looking a little bit into it and what
it's about so the description says it's
a small airfield which is now available
for use for well turning it into some
kind of theme park and as a sort of
special challenge it states that all of
the old structures or landmarks so we're
not going to be able to remove any of
the existing like terminals and hangar
buildings so that's something to keep in
mind and then the goals are a little bit
of a step up from the last scenario but
not too much so 250 guests in the park
and the optional go of 400 Park tickets
now I looked into this a tiny bit this
is a scenario made by Joshua from the US
and I am pretty sure that this is based
on the airfield or the Air Force Base in
Illinois in the US which is also called
Chanute and it's now been abandoned
since 1993 I think and I think the idea
to turn that into a theme park was
probably his and it's probably based on
the real-life Air Force Base in any case
I should start the scenario and see if
we can turn this into anything
all right so these are just the basic
goals and the map is quite simple it's
just the runway actually so it's it's a
bit of a weird shape to build a theme
park in so I'm also really curious if I
can turn that into anything good and
there are some interesting scenery
there's a little airplane on the roof
here and this really cool I don't know
what you call those things in English
actually whatever that thing the first
thing that came to mind was a wind sock
I don't know if that's actually what you
call it that's a bit of a weird word
isn't it anyway we've got that thing
over there that's pretty cool it's
outside the boundaries of the park
though so maybe I'll buy some land to go
there anyway this is just a very simple
runway and that's all but I don't think
I'll be raising this runway to the
ground and replacing it with grass I
could technically do that because it's
just terraforming
but I kind of like the idea of keeping
all of the airport infrastructure intact
and trying to theme the park after the
airport so I think we'll try that
shouldn't be too difficult seeing that
we only need to get 250 guests into the
park and then over here this sort of air
or airplane storage thing is really just
the depot or all of the supplies come in
so that's really interesting so we'll
need to have some kind of background or
backstage area over here where all the
staff can mingle in any case I'm just
about ready to start building a few
rides and the small food courts in this
park maybe even a roller coaster or two
that said I do want to know what we
actually have so we have the plane
carousel of course then some very simple
thrill rides and oh these are all really
small coasters okay that's that's
definitely something to keep in mind I
think that's good though I really like
it when you start out a scenario and
especially when the first scenario is
start out with very simple and easy
rides and you only get into the more
interesting and unique coasters later on
that's something which I think roller
coaster tycoon did which I enjoyed a lot
and then well of course they can to you
just get all of the rides straight from
the start which is terrible I think it's
cool to sort of get a progression in
terms of what kind of rise you get I do
think I want to research something now
so I'm just gonna hire a research team
not give them too much money and have
them and just look into thrill rides in
any case I think it's a good time for a
time-lapse I'll build a few rides and a
food court and we'll see what comes out
of it all right now I'm starting off
with the food courts and it's a little
bit more big and rectangular than I
would normally want to do normally I
would totally recommend against building
big boxy buildings because it's really
hard to make them look nice and inviting
but I think with the theme that we have
in the map here it really just fits to
make very large rectangular boxy
buildings and I think I'm just gonna
keep them all very boring and simple on
purpose to fit with the theme of the
sort of industrial air field kind of
look and I'll try to make all of the
deck
relations to be more sort of add-ons to
the existing buildings so all kinds of
path elements and planters and little
details to kind of spruce up the look of
the buildings but keep the look of the
building's themselves to be sort of as
if they weren't designed with a theme
park in mind because that's the idea
right it's a bit of a conversion of
former airfield into a probably slightly
nicer place to be and I think for the
food court it mostly works as well
because it's not sitting in a place
which is a runway it's kind of between
all the different runways runways and
places for airplanes so that more or
less should work I think but then for
the rest of the park I'll also try to
keep some of the buildings a little bit
smaller I suppose and see if I can fit
the large buildings that I do want to
build just outside the runway to kind of
make it seem really as if this is a very
recent conversion and there isn't really
anything new and like large builds on
the former runway anyway I moved into
the first ride which of course is the
little airplane ride I thought it'd be
cool to have a bit of a hangar kind of
look to the cube roof as well and I just
looked this up actually and I feel like
such an idiot I know I pronounced it as
hunger earlier which is the way that you
pronounce it in Dutch and it's the way
that you pronounce the word
in French is well I'm pretty sure so
that's just more or less how I thought
you'd say it in English but apparently
it's hanger so I need to correct myself
there anyway it sounds weird I don't
know hunger sounds a little bit nicer
but maybe that's just me being used that
in any case so we're moving into the
runway and I'm just building some of the
flat rides along the sides of the real
runway and then I'll be building a
coaster and other such sort of
transportable looking stuff on the
runway itself so what I'm also trying to
do here is that because this is such a
recent conversion from an air 4 or
airfield force air force field base
thing into a theme park trying to also
make all of the rides look a bit like
they are transportable rights so I don't
to get into
coasters that snake around the park but
kind of make everything look a little
bit more like a fairground so all of the
rights so far are quite simple and don't
really have too much immersive theming
and then for the coaster which I'll be
starting on in a second that's just
going to be a very small mini coaster
with a very transportable so the
fairground look to it so yeah here we go
here's the the coaster which I think
should also be called a Walt Mouse it's
a wild mouse in any case and these
things just work so well in this game I
think it always helps to just make them
go down on a very gentle slope on the
curves on the hairpin turns so you can
have every section of the hairpin to be
a little bit lower than the section
before that because in real life these
things are also built on a very slight
incline so you can kind of see the the
turns go down a little bit as they go so
yeah we've got that and then we're
moving into the more intense part of the
layouts where you always have these
drops and it's always this signature
drop which kind of has a bit of a hill
in the middle of it so I decided to add
that as well I'm not sure if a lot of
these have these I think they are more
common on the spinning ball Mouse
coasters but I'm pretty sure you see
them on these kinds of rides too anyway
I never trust these things they're
always painful they there are some of
the most bootleg rides in theme parks
but it fits the theme of this park so I
figured why not it's also pretty good
coaster from a gameplay perspective to
get something with some really good
stats and a pretty decent intensity on a
very small footprint and a very low cost
so it works pretty well from that
perspective as well also and god this is
a totally different kind of game but I
really was reminded and reminded of it
there's a YouTube channel called Marcel
Voss who does videos about open RCT to
showing the best kinds of layouts for
all kinds of roller coasters in roller
coaster tycoon and it's one of my
favorite channels recently it's really
cool stuff really going into the science
of what makes a roller coaster good in
that game and even though it's a
different game I think to some extent a
lot of the
ideas that he brings are translatable
into parks tanks as well so always
trying to keep your coasters cheap and
compact while trying to get you know the
biggest bang for your buck basically
trying to get the largest heights and
the fastest speeds in the smallest
layouts and it's just a generally good
idea if you not only want to get
something that's decent from a gameplay
perspective but you can also mix this
pretty well with a bit of realism as
well since a lot of theme parks will
obviously want to go for the same kind
of thing the theme parks that have the
money to spend all their cash on an
enormous ride are few and far between
and most parks realistically we'll just
go for smaller rides and even
second-hand roller coasters in any case
that's just about it for this time lapse
so let's head back into your real time
section and see what it looks like all
right now we're gonna have to make this
park function somehow so I think for now
just one janitor should be enough we are
gonna need one hauler over here and come
to think of it I probably also need a
way to connect this part to the parts in
the park itself so I'm probably just
gonna make a gate or something over here
I'm not quite sure yet but of course the
stuff that I do have is gonna need a way
to go over here and go to the staff room
or whatever else I end up building there
for now though it should be more or less
fine that should be alright enough
without a staff room for a while
and I just opened up everything
including the park but it seems like
people are already finding their way
more or less that said I don't know
about all of the prices this seems to be
good enough I was taught that for some
of the bigger coasters you can ask about
2.5 times the excitement rating but I'm
really not sure yeah and how much money
you can ask for right so I'm really
gonna have to sort of discover that
along the way but I think for this one I
could try asking $7 for it and we'll see
if people want to spend that money
looking at this coaster though I think I
want to close it down for a second I
didn't think about that but you
generally don't want to have the maximum
amount of trains that you can on
the certain amount of blocks that you
have any coaster since well that just
makes all of the cars stuck on the block
breaks all the time so somebody was
asking this in the comment section of
the last video as well basically if you
have book breaks this sort of divides
the coaster up into different blocks and
you are only allowed to really have one
car on a single block at a time it's
sort of an inherent safety mechanism of
a roller coaster which makes sure that
coaster cars can never crash into each
other because you can never be on the
same block as another car and if it does
end up happening then you'll suddenly be
stopped on the brakes so that's also why
sometimes if you're on a coaster you
just get these filin brakes and you just
have to stop for a second and if that's
happening it's just because there's
still a train or a car on the block in
front of you and they're trying to avoid
that so when a crash does happen it's
usually because of a block brake failure
and in the case of the smiler crash in
Alton Towers for instance this was
actually due to human failure because
somebody at the buttons was overriding
the block brakes because the block brake
system is a completely automated system
and given that everything works it
should never go wrong and pretty much
keep a coaster 100% feel safe in any
case that's a bit of a long explanation
about that but the reason that I don't
have too many cars on these coasters
when you do rely on block brake sections
is that there will always be a car on
the Block in front of you if you have
the maximum amount of cars so they'll
almost always stop on the block sections
and that's a bit annoying you want to
try and time them in such a way that the
cars never really have to stop that said
I'm still seeing the cars stopping on
some of the blip on some of these brakes
I think it's not a big issue at the end
here and it's not really a big issue at
the beginning either but this one I
would like to not have it do that so
actually I wonder and this is a bit of a
gameplay test but I wonder if you can
have to block brakes in a row and if
that's just going to create another
block or knots okay so we're gonna put a
block brake over here
and one over here does that increase the
amount of yeah that doesn't increase the
amount of cars so this won't add an
extra block that's good to know
in that case I'm need to I'm gonna need
to find a different solution to that
problem I suppose and I'm thinking about
dividing the station into an entrance in
turn and an exit section yeah that would
actually be quite good so I'm gonna need
to figure out a way to make this look
nicer but realistically you want to have
one place where the people exit the car
and then it moves a little bit to
another part of the station where people
enter the new train so I'm just gonna
put this in here put an extra block
break in there then we can add two extra
books that's amazing I'm gonna have
seven trains and run it like that's and
then I'm just gonna have to see if I can
theme it very nicely so realistically
this is actually the way to go this is
how a lot of these coasters will work
the only problem is from a from a
gameplay perspective you won't have the
platform for this station in the middle
so it looks a little bit weird so I'm
just gonna try to fill this in with some
kind of law anything that I've used
before I also got the question on the
last video if I keep like a certain set
of textures or a certain set of colors
ready and really you can save color
schemes like these things over here but
as you might be able to notice these are
super old color schemes I think from
back when I was working on Cydonia Hills
so that's a long time ago so I actually
don't really use the color scheme
function I just used the pipettes tool
and go around copying the colors of
objects that I placed earlier like this
and then just replace it like so and I
think that more or less works I really
don't see a reason to do anything else
than that's because it just it doesn't
take too much effort and you don't have
to keep saving all of these different
color schemes all right now I think if I
make this a little bit lighter it'll
look tiny bit better Oh God not like
that's there we go I'll just keep the
station like that unfortunately I can't
really see it test anymore because it
just broke down because of the actually
I don't think it's broken down I think
it's just not running because there's a
thunderstorm and it's too dangerous but
in any case
is gonna open it like this it should be
more or less fine and then we'll see how
that'll go now I'm not actually getting
any supplies being delivered to these
places so okay she's working all right I
think just Sarah over here should be
able to handle all of the supplies but
not entirely sure we'll see how that
goes but I'll just leave her work alone
for the time being and I'm just gonna
hook this up over here make sure that
the employees can actually go somewhere
that said I kind of want to try my best
to hide this a little bit because it's
probably affecting the decoration rating
oh yeah god that's terrible so I don't
know if I explained this too much but
you get a decoration rating in the game
and it's based on how many decorations
the guests see so you can see over here
it's really good but if they see
backstage elements and yeah I have
briefly explained this but not really
showing it that well if they see
backstage elements this really detracts
from the decoration rating so this is
all red over here because they are
looking at the staff room here and
that's not something that guests to want
to see so I'm actually gonna test this
for a little bit see if we can put
something over here probably not this
but hold up let me get back to that see
if we can see it change to the live now
that actually doesn't help at all maybe
maybe a small pavilion will work I don't
know let's get this out of here
let's give it that sort of color call
that's actually gonna be difficult I'm
gonna have to hide that better I'm not
gonna keep that in there definitely not
because I want to keep that rating
positive so if all goes well and if I
place a fence over here yeah and then
the rating becomes a lot better there we
go it's all green again okay so we are
doing good there I think if I put a tree
over here maybe the rating will become a
little bit better still okay yeah
there we go all green oh okay so that's
awesome the rating over here is really
bad because there's a broken-down bench
and actually mechanic should fix these
things but I'm not gonna wait for that
so let's just put it there and there we
go that fixed itself I'm just gonna have
to find a little pathway somewhere where
I can probably enter from in here and
hide the path to the backstage area a
little bit better in any case seems like
the park is running all rights who are
not quite making a profit yet but we're
making less of a loss so that's pretty
good and it seems like people are
willing to pay $7 for a tiny Walt Mouse
ride that's a ripoff but I mean people
are paying for it so let's just go for
it and this is way too cheap so let's go
and let's make that 450 and now this can
also be a bit more expensive I think
they'll be willing to pay $4 for that
and then there's the ferris wheel I
wonder how that's doing because these
things are not actually that useful but
that seems to be doing all right so
we're all making money everywhere that's
pretty good except this one but this
will probably end up making money in due
time so overall not too shabby I think
I'm gonna have to wait a little bit
longer to see if the bike is actually
doing all right but so far I think we're
off to a decent start
I can probably head back into a small
time lapse and I'll probably be able to
reach the guest go with the remaining
seven thousand dollars left so yeah
let's go
all right now I didn't think that I
would need too many more rides since
there were already quite a few guests in
the park and I already paused the game
to make sure that not too many other
guests were still entering so I'm just
building this one Riptide right and
that's just about it the majority of
this time left will be spent on a kiddie
coaster or it's more of a family coaster
I think the coaster that it's based on
in real life is the bakoma roller skater
so it's you know not the smallest kind
of coaster in the world it's a step up
from the absolute mini transportable
kiddie coaster but it's a good one for
the kids anyway
a lot of pikes have it so I thought it'd
be nice to a feature in the park I might
not even really need it in terms of
reaching the guest counts since I ended
up reaching the guest counts much
earlier than I expected again and going
over it quite a bit as well when I just
let the game play at the end of my
playthrough but I think from from a
perspective of just looking at this park
as its own the whole park regardless of
what scenario goals I need to reach I
thought it would just be fitting to
include a small kiddie coaster anyway I
thought here would be a good area it's
also a bit of an outskirts it's pretty
far away from the entrance so I wanted
to stop the whole pathing experience
over here and just finish this side of
the park off with a small roller coaster
and I think this should do the job
pretty well it's also one of my
favourite coasters to build in the game
just because it's quite simple in terms
of layout it doesn't really use any
unique elements or anything complicated
but I think it works really well with
the combination of banking turns and
height differences that you can get in
park attacks because one of my absolute
favorite things about this games track
mechanism is that you don't really have
to choose from a set like number of
pieces kind of like you had to in games
like rollercoaster tycoon
you more or less just selects the
banking and the curve and the level that
you want to go up and down for each
track piece and you're completely free
in making weird combinations so you can
even make outward banked curves if you
so desire to do that and you can make
all kinds of transitions going from
straights to gentle to steep slopes as
well during a curve as well as going
from all kinds of banking transitions so
I think that sort of system works really
well for coasters like these where you
don't really have to deal with too many
special elements and you're just kind of
meandering in and out of the layouts so
I really like building these things it's
just a simple little layout with some
helixes not too many drops I think it's
way too terrible when it comes to the
stats it doesn't actually have much of
an intensity rating at all but it
decently realistic that's why I like it
and it fits well with the theme as well
I think it doesn't really need a lot of
theming so I just put a little airplane
down and some flags on the side there to
make everything look a little bit more
fancy this was lowkey inspired by energy
London in Poland which has terrible
theming but I think they do the theming
for their formula 1 coaster pretty well
so that was a bit of an inspiration for
this one and then the station is also
just a simple modern glossy station I
also decided to add some more lights
throughout the park since Park tech has
a night mode and I always forget to
switch to it but it's always fun to look
at your park at nights as well and since
the runway didn't have any of those
runway lights I just decided to add
those as well for some random reason I
think it works alright though and
definitely for some of the darker parts
of the park it helps to light those up
as well
so that's basically it for the coaster
area I decided to last minute and a
Gravitron and originally I also wanted
to add another flat ride besides this
one but I let the game play as you can
see and I didn't actually pause it well
at the right time I pause it over here
but eventually I ended up reaching the
guest count much earlier than I thought
so I couldn't entirely finish it in any
case let's look back and what the park
ends up looking like alright so I had
250 guests way earlier than I thought so
I'm pretty much done I suppose with the
scenario but it seems a little bit
unfinished still so what I think I'm
gonna do is I just want to put one
little ride if I have the money for that
actually over here to maybe finish off
the park although that said I guess I
really don't have the money for that I
might as well just put a little fence
over here and call it a day and I
suppose see I think I'm actually just
gonna do that as long as these guests
are getting out of the way I can
actually close it up over here okay
nevermind that's that's not gonna be
doable alright let's just
which were these guys to be done well
there we go and I'll just round up the
park over here don't think there's much
else that I can still really do so I'll
just put a fence over here and then
we'll call it a day let's open up the
Gravitron so I was originally thinking I
could still maybe build another ride
over here but I hit the goal much
earlier and I don't actually have that
much money either so this is gonna have
to be it I suppose let's just put a
quick fence over here I don't know I
think it just kind of fits to put a
fence to kind of fence off the areas
which even though they're part of the
park aren't really part of the park to
visit in a way so let's just put that in
there and maybe just a few final plants
there in there and that should pretty
much finish up the park right one of
these trees there we go I think that's
pretty good alright so this is the park
in its final stage I'm pretty happy with
it I think it follows the theme which
the map gives pretty well it doesn't
really have any interesting or detailed
buildings or anything but just by
keeping the variety of rides and all
kinds of small path elements and
decorations I still think it's a pretty
charming and cozy theme park to the
extent that an airfield can be that I
suppose and I'm actually quite happy
with the rise as well we still don't
have any big roller coasters I still
think they're not really parts of these
first scenarios maybe you could get into
that if you research them and spend a
lot of money on it but really there
isn't enough time or resources to really
get into that sort of stuff in the first
scenario so I think it fits to just
start off with these very small junior
and family coasters and will maybe get
into some bigger stuff later on so yeah
overall I'm pretty happy with the
results it's also making a lot of money
a lot more than I thought really I still
think it's a little bit easy but that
said I don't to say that too soon
because I know how hard some of these
later scenarios are gonna get
so we're doing pretty good so far and
I'm very happy with this park and yeah
I'll see you guys next time when we move
into the next one which I believe is
going to be Victoria Lake but I'll have
to check that again in the next episode
so yeah bye guys